by popular demand Who Framed Roger
Rabbit a lot of people have been asking
me to do this film and I guess I can
sort of see why it is technically Disney
animation even though it's mixed with
live-action
it had groundbreaking technology and it
was the first time you saw characters
like Mickey Mouse and Bugs Bunny
together that's still so surreal to me
I'll spill the story real quick for all
what two of you that don't know it Eddie
valiant played by Bob Hoskins is a
detective in Hollywood apparently a very
wealthy prankster named Marvin Acme has
been murdered by a - Eddie doesn't mind
too much seeing how he has this
incredible prejudice against tooms why
because a tomb killed his brother how
dropped the piano on his head that is
hilariously tragic everybody thinks
Roger Rabbit is to blame and so he goes
to Eddie valiant to try and solve the
case despite his prejudice he does
believe that the rabbit is innocent and
so with the help of the characters from
toontown including Roger saucy hot wife
named Jessica they set out to solve the
mystery I'm trying to think what I can
say about this film that everybody else
hasn't already everybody's seen it
everybody loves it in fact they more
than love it they go crazy for it so ok
let's talk about why people go crazy for
this film cuz to be honest I never quite
understood I mean don't get me wrong I
go crazy for it too I am in love with
this movie but I mean everybody in the
world seems to like this film even the
biggest Sauer poisons is it the story
yes but I don't know it's not really
much of a mystery I mean take a guess
who the bad guy is no really come on
take a wild guess
is it the characters well yeah they're
pretty good too but again nothing really
groundbreaking we've seen characters
with prejudices before and they go
through a story arc that changes them
back is it how technically
groundbreaking it is I suppose but
there's a lot of technological
groundbreaking movies that people don't
go gaga for I like to do with this movie
even the idea of live action actors
interacting with cartoons is not a new
idea it's been done almost since the
beginning of animation so really what's
the secret formula that everybody can
identify with well I thought about why I
like the movie I mean sure the story and
characters are great but what is it I
love about it now that I love just as
much as when I was a kid
then it hit me this is the movie I
always wanted to see as a kid the fields
very clever and not taking modern-day
cartoons but rather the timeless
cartoons that everybody grew up with
they are the characters that fill up the
screen and like I said before it's not
just Disney characters it's Warner
Brothers characters paramount characters
it runs the gamut and I can guarantee
you everybody that has ever grown up
watching cartoons as envisioned this
imagining a film or a story where every
single one of their favorite cartoon
characters come together and that's what
this movie did it brought everybody's
childhood fantasy total life it made
these cartoon characters that we grew up
with breathed it treated them with the
same dedication and love that we felt
every single time we watch them you
don't see a modern-day manipulation of
Bugs Bunny
you see Bugs Bunny you don't see a
writer trying to recreate Mickey Mouse
you see Mickey Mouse and because it was
set in the past everybody knows these
characters and absolutely love them and
because of the technology they have they
see more real than ever and a good story
some scary moments funny moments
dramatic moments romantic moments top it
off with some great writers and a good
director who put all their time and
energy into making these characters seem
just as real alive and believable to us
now as they were when we were children
and you have a movie that captures all
the zany inist all the goofiness and all
the joy that we felt as children
watching these cartoons quite honestly
it's a perfectly written love letter to
our childhoods
you